in terms of what it means for the actual
War it's worth mentioning that vaginal
was currently being held in reserve
really reconstituting itself after the
meat grinder of the bakmud war
that means that it was really going to
be used as a reinforcement element so it
was a small force that was ready for it
when the ukrainians punched through the
main defensive lines
even if its forces are being sent
elsewhere that does mean that one of the
most effective elements in the Russian
military is not going to be available
when the counter-offensive reaches that
kind of critical stage so in the short
term at least this is an advantage for
Kiev